Sam farmer LA Times NFL national writer
and he was at the Niners Rams game on
Sunday which we'll talk about Sam thanks
for getting up early with us what do you
make of pass interference and the replay
of these like I don't know what's going
on but it almost feels like it's
deliberate yeah I mean I don't love that
segue somebody who's average at his job
[Laughter]
it's really frustrating it's almost you
know there was a the non call in the
Giants Patriots game in Golden Tate
basically at his hands handcuffed behind
them and you're not going to call that
it's almost like flaunting it like look
yes we're not changing this and and it's
kind of like why why make the change it
why go through all the trouble of
talking about reviewing past their fair
as if it's just going to be so arbitrary
and and almost impossible to change a
call in the field is this all based on
the Rams and Saints and and I you know a
creating a system where you know you can
save yourself in the playoffs but I mean
you gotta have some consistency here and
some of these things are just ridiculous
yeah I just I start to wonder even if
they had this you know new system in
place in the Saints Rams game they might
have gotten that one wrong to the way
things are going here I mean it's just
yeah it just seems so cosmetic right now
and and right as a cosmetic start
working people see that Zoe's you know
the officials are going to stick with
their call on the field unless you know
there's some arbitrary reason they don't
I knew but there's no consistency to it
right now
Hey McLovin gives Sam the poll question
okay who's in the most trouble the
Chiefs
the Rams or the Cowboys boy I'd have to
say the Cowboys of the ham but the
Cowboys fans kind of got drunk on that
start you know they'd eat the Giants
with the I and the Redskins with the
dolphins and everybody thought
they were rolling but you know you look
that they don't have its two starting
tackles they don't have the two best
receivers and they got the Eagles coming
up there they're at the Giants with with
daniel Jones better Giants team and then
they play the Vikings so I think we're
kind of a sneaky Super Bowl team right
now out of the NSC so I think the
Cowboys are in the most trouble of those
teams you got a chance to see the Rams
and the Niners let me start with the
Niners how good are they you know that
they are they're exceptional defensively
you know they're 500 for the first time
since 1990 but you know they did this
without one they're both starting
tackles or got out they didn't never
starting fullback a corner a nickel
corner they lost in the game but I mean
just what they did defensively when you
look at that stat line the Rams who were
the last two years one of the best
offenses in the league they were over
nine on third down now this is at home
they were over four on fourth down
you know I Jimmy Garoppolo is 13 - as a
starter hasn't even started a complete
season yet if you cram all it starts
together and so now they play at
Washington I mean they're a really
really good team and everything is sort
of coming together the way Cal Shannon
and John Lynch had envisioned but very
quickly so I really like the Niners is
Sean McVeigh still genius you know I
mean I think he's an excellent coach I
don't know if I ever called him a genius
but he's still an excellent coach look
if that kick in Seattle you know is one
foot to the left the whole narrative
changes now they are in a tough stretch
right now definitely their offensive
light their foundational cracks of the
ramps I mean their offensive line is a
problem right now and it's going to get
worse they've lost your Noteboom and you
know Todd Gurley is not Todd Gurley but
he showed flashes
in Seattle being that that player he
once was and you know defensively
they're struggling up front if you're
going to stop the run and I think that
limits what Aaron Donald can do is still
probably the best player in the league
right now but they've got a soft cushion
because they play at Atlanta and they
play Cincinnati in London and then they
had their bye
so they have a couple of weeks to sort
of catch their breath right now anything
can happen I mean Tampa Bay came across
country beat them and Jameis Winston
looked like Tom Brady but I think that
the Rams when you look at you said the
Chiefs the Rams and the Cowboys the Rams
sort of have a chance to catch up now
catch their breath and win a couple of
games talking to Sam farmer the NFL
national writer for the LA Times
second-best team in the AFC is look
across the board you know I you know
cheesehead back-to-back losses at home
okay I still think they're a great team
you know the teams are sort of figuring
out if we can play keep-away now granted
their defenses is is it bad and they
can't stop the run they're getting up to
five point three yards of carry so teams
are playing keep away from Patrick
mahomes I still think that's a really
good team now I don't think the
second-best team you see right now but
yeah I mean it's just one of those years
again where the Patriots are sort of
running away with it there's you look at
the West the south I mean Houston's
interesting the north I mean boy that's
I guess Bolton okay yeah like I sort of
settled on them I said there's not a
second-best team so I gave Baltimore the
third best team in the AFC you know and
when I'm watching the Chargers game last
night there are a lot of Steeler fans
there Sam if the Chargers all of a
sudden left Los Angeles would anybody
know
yeah I mean that's that's really a tough
situation now granted we kind of knew
that the Steelers would take over a
stadium it's not surprising that plight
their fans are the best traveling fans
in the league but that this is happening
every week even with teams that don't
travel as well they're taken over at
least half the stadium and I think that
if you're if you're a great team you can
overcome that but if you're a team where
every feather on the scale counts that
has a devastating cumulative effect
psychologically if you're never playing
a home game and the Chargers never have
a home field advantage ever and you know
I I just you think about the team moving
into a new stadium and I kind of acquit
and some people said you know things
will be better when the Chargers move
into the new stadium I kind of equate
that to my wife and I will stop fighting
once we have children it's only gonna
complicate move into this 70,000 seat
stadium when right now in a 27,000 seat
stadium it's half the opposing fan so
it's really it's hard to envision this
ending well for the Chargers and for the
NFL really because the whole notion of
LA being a two-team market is sort of
blown up by this and you know this is a
this is a market that for 20 years
consumed football from the couch and
watched on TV and it's only gotten worse
and so now trying to sort of flood the
engine with two teams it's really
difficult in 10 years do you think the
Chargers are still in Los Angeles boy I
would not be surprised if they were not
it's you knows the weird I just don't
see how this gets better from here
because you know and
and it's it's moving the needle how do
you move the needle in Los Angeles and
and it's hard enough for the Rams to
move the needle especially because you
think about everybody now has a super
short attention span red zone channel is
you know people like that that sort of
quick hit thing and so attending changes
is not as compelling as it once was
you got fantasy football has taken hold
it's really tough you know I'd love to
get it give a definitive answer on
whether the charge will be here and I
just don't know how you solved that
riddle at this point Sam great to talk
to you again thanks for joining us yeah
my pleasure guys anytime that's a Sam
former LA Times NFL national writer ball
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]